♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE DESPERATE,
LAWLESS DEMOCRATS.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
"ANGLE."
♪ ♪
MY FRIENDS ACROSS THE POLITICAL
AISLE ARE CHEERING THE SUPREME
COURT'S 574 DECISION TODAY THAT
STRUCK DOWN ON VAGUENESS
GROUNDS, A FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION STATUTE THAT TRIGGER
IMMIGRATION STATUTE THAT TRIGGED
DEPORTATION FOR INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF VIOLENT CRIMES.
THE ILLEGAL ALIEN IN THE CASE
HAD BEEN ARRESTED FOR BURGLARY,
WHICH BOTH THE OBAMA AND TRUMP
DOJ ARGUED SHOULD TRIGGER
DEPORTATION.
WHY?
THE DEFENDANT'S CONDUCT POSED A
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF VIOLENCE.
WELL OF NEIL GORSUCH, THE NEWEST
JUSTICE OF THE COURT, APPLIED A
TEXTUAL LIST APPROACH IN
DECIDING TO JOIN THE LIBERAL
JUSTICES IN THE MAJORITY.
JUSTICES ROBERTS, THOMAS, ALITO,
AND KENNEDY DISSENTED ON GROUNDS
THAT THE STATUTE'S LANGUAGE WAS
PLENTY CLEAR.
BUT LOOK, SETTING ASIDE WHICH
THEORY OF STATUTORY
INTERPRETATION IS MOST FAITHFUL
TO THE CONSTITUTION, DO ANY OF
YOU WONDER WHY THIS IS AN ISSUE
AT ALL?
I MEAN, LOOK, ANYONE HERE
ILLEGALLY, EXCEPT THAT DACA
PEOPLE, IS POTENTIALLY A
DEPORTABLE ALIEN UNDER CURRENT
LAW.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU DON'T
HAVE PERMISSION TO BE HERE, THE
HOME.
MAYBE THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T
DEPORT 12 MILLION PEOPLE.
WE HEAR THAT ALL THE TIME.
BUT A SEARCH OF MAY COME THEY
COULD REPORT A LOT IF THEY
WANTED TO.
DEMOCRATS, HOWEVER, ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN ENFORCING THE LAW.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE INTERESTED IN
GROWING THEIR VOTER ROLLS.
AND THE DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T
EVEN RECOGNIZE VICTIMS OF
ILLEGAL ALIEN CRIMES.
REMEMBER, ACCORDING TO REPORTS,
JAMIL SHAW'S FATHER SAID HE
NEVER RECEIVED A CALL FROM
PRESIDENT OBAMA AFTER HE LOST
HIS SON.
BUT REMEMBER, HE FOUND TIME,
PRESIDENT OBAMA, TO CALL THAT
OTHER VICTIM, BUT I DIGRESS.
GOVERNOR JERRY "MR. SANCTUARY"
BROWN WAS IN WASHINGTON TODAY
AND HE WAS ASKED ABOUT THE
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA REJECTING
HIS SANCTUARY POLICY.
REMEMBER, THE SANCTUARY LAWS FOR
BETA STATE AND LOCAL POLICE
AGENCIES FROM EVEN NOTIFYING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHEN
INCARCERATED ILLEGALS ARE ABOUT
TO BE RELEASED ONTO THE STREETS.
>> THE LEADERS OF THESE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES, FOR MANY YEARS TO
SHERIFFS, ARE SAYING THAT YOUR L
SHERIFFS, ARE SAYING THAT YOUR W
SHERIFFS, ARE SAYING THAT YOUR F
SHERIFFS, ARE SAYING THAT YOUR V
SHERIFFS, ARE SAYING THAT YOUR R
SHERIFFS, ARE SAYING THAT YOUR S
THE RIGHTS OF CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL ALIENS OVER THE
RIGHTS AND THE SAFETY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> ABSOLUTELY FALSE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A SCINTILLA
OF EVIDENCE OF SUPPORT THAT
OUTLANDISH BOX PROPOSITION.
>> THAT'S NOT A FOX PROPOSITION.
>> I THINK FOX NEWS EXPLOITS
THIS ISSUE.
WE HAVE CRIMINALS THAT DO
HORRIBLE THINGS ALL THE TIME.
WHICH ONES MAY BE DOCUMENTED AND
WHICH ONES AREN'T, OTHER GUYS
WILL LOOK AT THAT.
WE HAVE A VERY STRONG
I THINK THE SCAPEGOAT OF THE
IMMIGRANTS BY THESE VERY BIASED
STORIES, --
>> WITH ALL DUE RESPECT --
>> I WANT TO PROTECT PEOPLE.
FOR YOU TO SAY THAT WE DON'T
CARE ABOUT VICTIMS IS REALLY
TROUBLING.
>> Laura: "WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT," SOME OF YOUR OWN
COUNTY OFFICIALS ARE SAYING YOUR
POLICIES DON'T SEEM TO CARE
ABOUT VICTIMS PAST OR FUTURE.
JUST YESTERDAY, LOS ALAMITOS
VOTED 4-WANT TO ALIGN THEMSELVES
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND OPPOSING BROWN SANCTUARY
STATE POLICY.
TODAY, SAN DIEGO COUNTY VOTED TO
DO THE SAME.
WOW.
HOW LONG CAN JERRY BROWN ALLOW
THIS TO GO ON?
HE IS CARRYING HIS DATE -- HE'S
TEARING HIS DATE APART AND HE'S
ENDANGERING
THE
CITIZENS.
NOW BROWN IS WAFFLING ON HER
RESPONSE --
GOVERNOR MOONBEAM SAYS HE IS
WILLING TO SEND 400 TROOPS, SO
LONG AS THEY HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
WHERE THEY BUILD SCHOOLS?
REGARDLESS OF THE THREAT THEY
MIGHT PRESENT TO THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA, ILLEGALS, THEY ARE
ALWAYS WELCOME, SO LONG AS THE
LIBERALS ARE IN CHARGE THERE.
THIS IS CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN BRAD SHERMAN, WHO
WAS WITH ME ON THE "ANGLE" A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
>> YOU HAVE MORE CRIME ON
CALIFORNIA THEN WYOMING BECAUSE
YOU HAVE MORE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> Laura: HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TONIGHT
THAT IF -- BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
WANTS TO BE SANCTUARY, FUGITIVE
STATE, WE HAVE TO SACRIFICE A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF AMERICANS FOR
THIS UTOPIAN IDEA THAT BORDERS
ARE POINTLESS?
>> THE FACT IS, IF YOU WANT TO
LESS CRIME, MOVED TO THE
CAYMAN ISLANDS.
THEY'VE GOT SO FEW PEOPLE THERE,
YOU CAN GO A WHOLE WEEK WITHOUT
A VIOLENT CRIME.
>> Laura: THAT IS THEIR
ARGUMENT?
IF YOU WANT TO BE SAFE FROM
ILLEGALS, MOVED TO THE
CAYMAN ISLANDS?
MY FRIENDS, THIS IS MADNESS.
AS I OFTEN SAY, IF ENFORCING OUR
IMMIGRATION LAWS SPARES ONE
AMERICAN FROM DEATH OR RAPE OR